yeah welcome to this video playing
health health match from Norway right
yes ok so the coke on check transposing
to the front steve larson he hasn't
played d4 and he doesn't yeah not sure
that this means anything specific maybe
he's aiming for a form yeah not much
choice I cannot tolerate her him play f4
f5 but that's not a big deal he needs to
retreat it and then I have Bishop age 5
or take on g6 witchy what would you
avoid it so how to play now
now why not just use the g how i can
easily castle along here we're not sure
as if i should take the night 95 is a
move that can get in can get annoying
let's just just take it opener or 35
yeah the Sun cannot be too bad
defending h7 on bishops III I can play
Bishop f6 shouldn't be a big issue it
all is is slightly shaky need to admit
that
yeah okay he can take them on f6 been
under some circumstances show is
dangerous I'd like to Castle long
obviously I thought rook rook g6 would
would be okay
yeah he can he can retreat to age three
and this son didn't help much then
hmm yeah night reform
hmm yeah he's taking on g6 a pirate I
move the night is taking on g6 intending
rupiah 898 is also taking 26 I'm sorry
yeah I don't see a really satisfactory
move
hmm I can't play that but it's looking
okay it's not the move you want to play
the ideas takes takes an 8-h takes 36
check and King needs em yeah this should
be ok actually check
I can take a 6mm and then take f7 would
have been okay
yeah this isn't isn't a big problem
actually I'm porn down but it's cell
opposite colored bishops and team can
hardly make any progress this will be a
matter of time play
yeah it's two points but how does he
does he make any substantial progress
here check aha Bishop g1 mate mate
threatened ok avoided King age free
yeah this is just a role this position
check check I didn't didn't really look
too closely here check but still should
be at wrong time warning check check
draw our third game drawn no that's a
rabbit hmm yeah of course its debt it's
almost almost symmetrical the other the
transposition into the endgame wasn't so
dangerous probably had some some better
some better news now you can take f6
here this is much better now and here
Queen g6 again this it cave isn't term
isn't so fatal I mean white or cost was
better is kind to bonds but it's it's
not easy to convert this is threatened
and the bishop will get a very strong
post on d4 so this is I mean is it's two
pawns but it's essentially just one pond
eh poll and yeah this is how to promote
so it's not clear how to autumn place
right
yeah after that I got good actor farooq
check let's started to to get corns back
yeah cause I'm check maybe there may be
just okay i'm getting all the bones back
here yeah probably it's just the draw
the zen camp I'm still curious about
about this position after Queen each
form if I have some some good move there
yeah 95 94 94 is winning okay check now
they didn't calculate that but I
understand the general problem thus
maybe this check and then queen III was
some other way to her to directly attack
the king yeah I didn't did see that at
all I didn't even see 94 yeah this is
winning for black but ok no no way to
see that for me at least alright thanks
for watching